the most important scene for me for most
of the people of this city is about the
taxes they are taking they've been
robbing the city blind high for recent
TV I'm tim cavanaugh it is a beautiful
temperate Southern California night here
in the city of Bell where tempers are
boiling over at the recent revelations
of an $800,000 a year city manager
corruption from top to bottom in the
Bell City Council people have had enough
there is a massive protest going on
there's a City Council meeting inside
but this crowd tonight is demanding
nothing less than the resignation of
everybody on the City Council and the
mayor and as far as I can tell the dog
catchers discussing what they're doing
with our money it's all going into their
pockets I have lived in this city for 38
years I have never seen before this kind
of behavior from the city government
they're serving the people they're not
supposed to be making money out of us
who follow intensive purposes the city
of Bell has one of the highest tax rates
in the county I believe it's about one
point five seven percent of your
assessed value I think that's even
higher than the city of Beverly Hills
and property values are lower this year
than they were last year the real estate
market is down why are the taxes going
up
with more manga further making other
money for where do you think their
salaries are only pockets we have very a
very predatory government and community
members are trusting and I mean that's
anywhere in the United States our
governments working for the most part
right and so not until we realize it's
really broken and we step in all those
dollars good I must have I am Paolo
Santos I'm pretty sure that
self-explanatory she said everybody
let's go it looks like they're going to
be like they haven't I'm black of
monopoly and they want to take control
of the city and everything around it's
all coming out our pockets the eternal
taxes
akagi's keep going up and up and up and
up is it ten percent want a cos ten
percent of the bill of the hour the
water ten percent of the video the
telephone 10% of the on the wheel of the
electricity I want everyone to go and in
addition I would love for our
neighboring cities to be looked at as
well because if it's happening here I'm
pretty sure it's happening there too
this is a mafioso typist I'll go over me
I think this entire city council to just
resign and and have the Attorney General
come in here and the Registrar we cook
porter come in here and have whole new
elections and they like the new City
Council I definitely feel that this
needs to happen area where we have a
historic moment right now to make change
do it right and have it replicated
across the u.s.